♪
>> Tucker: CNN HAS BEEN SO
COMPLETELY OVER THE TOP IN
ITS COVERAGE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT THOSE OF
US WHO REMEMBER IT FROM 20
YEARS AGO OR WHO IN MY CASE
USED TO WORK THERE STARE
SLAP JAW AT THE SCREEN
REALLY CAN THIS BE
HAPPENING?
LAST NIGHT EVEN FARTHER THAN
NORMAL EDITORIALIZED IN ITS
KYRONS THE SCRIPT AT THE
FIRST IN THE SITUATION ROOM
ONE KYRON READ WHITE HOUSE
REPEATS FALSE CLAIM IS HE
TOUGHER ON RUSSIA THAN
OBAMA.
AS IF THAT'S AN OBJECTIVE
CLAIM.
MEAN WHILE UP FRONT WITH
ERIN BURNETT IT'S CLEAR
RUSSIAN MEDDLING HAD NO
IMPACT FOLLOWED BY IN
PARENTHESIS, NO, IT'S NOT.
FACT CHECKING OWN KYRON.
HAS A FACIAL TWITCH AND
JOINS US TONIGHT; JOE,
KYRONS, WE SHOULD BE FAIR TO
WOLF BLITZER WHO DOES TRY
HARD TO KEEP IT STRAIGHT,
THEY DON'T WRITE THE KYRONS
BUT LIKE NOBODY SAW THAT AND
SAID THAT'S TOO FAR, WE
CAN'T DO THAT.
>> OH, NO, OBVIOUSLY THAT
WAS A DECISION IN THE
CONTROL ROOM, TUCKER.
AND SAME WITH AARON BURNETT.
I HAVE BEEN ON HER SHOW A
COUPLE TIMES.
I RESPECT HER
PROFESSIONALLY.
I THINK SHE DOES A GOOD JOB.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY DECISION
AS FAR AS THOSE KYRONS.
AFTERWARDS THEY CAN READ THE
CRITICISM AND SAY HEY, GUYS,
IT'S MY FACE THAT'S ON THE
SCREEN.
I'M 00 ONLY ONE THAT'S GOING
TO GET CRITICISM FOR IT BUT
AND AN END TO IT KYRONS LIKE
WE ARE SEEING BELOW OUR
SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
EDITORIAL OPINION SHOW LIKE
YOURS IT'S FINE LIKE YOUR
NEWSPAPER.
YOU GO TO YOUR EDITORIAL
PAGE AND THAT'S FINE.
BUT ON NEWS PROGRAMS, THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT PLAYS INTO
THE NARRATIVE IF YOU ARE CNN
THAT YOU ARE THE OPPOSITION
PARTY, THAT YOU ARE LEADING
THE RESISTANCE AGAINST THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND NOT SERVE
AS AN OBJECTIVE NEWS
ORGANIZATION NOW, WHAT'S A
FACTUAL KYRON FOR INSTANCE
LIKE TODAY IN NEW YORK, NEW
YORK EXPERIENCED RECORD HIGH
TEMPERATURES IN CENTRAL
PARK.
THAT'S A FACT.
BILLY GRAHAM DIES AT AGE 99.
WHEN YOU HAVE BREAKING NEWS
WHITE HOUSE REPEATS TRUMP'S
FALSE CLAIM OBJECTIVE ON
RUSSIA:  SUM THIS UP BEST
SENIOR COUNSELOR FOR
MILITARY AND DEFENSE AFFAIRS
FOR SENATOR TOM COTTON AND
JOHN NOONAN IS NO RELATION
TO DANNY NOON NONE I WANT TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR CNN
RESPECTIVELY PLEASE TELL
YOUR PRODUCER NOT TO DO THIS
YOU CAN'T APPOINT YOURSELF
ARBITERS IN THE DEBATE.
DEBATE THE MERIT OF EACH
ADMINISTRATION'S POLICIES
THAT'S PERFECTLY FINE.
THIS ISN'T PUTTING YOUR
FINGER ON THE SCALE THAT'S
SITTING ON IT I THINK THAT
SUMS IT NICELY.
>> Tucker: THE TRUMP KYRON
IS A BANNER AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE SCREEN.
>> A HEADLINE.
>> Tucker: THAT THE HOST IS
NOT AWARE OF.
HAVE YOU NOTICED THIS ALL
DAY, THESE CABLE NEWS
ANCHORS MOST OF WHOM AS FAR
AS I KNOW ARE CHILDLESS
LECTURING THE REST OF US
ABOUT HOW WE DON'T LOVE THE
CHILDREN IF WE DON'T AGREE
WITH THEM ON VERY SPECIFIC
POLITICAL ISSUE, GUNS?
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THE PRESS
PREACHIER THAN IT WAS TODAY?
>> I REMEMBER ON THE GAY
MARRIAGE RULINGS A COUPLE
YEARS AGO A SIDE WAS TAKEN.
IT WAS A SIDE THAT MANY
AMERICANS AGREED WITH.
BUT YOU CAN'T DO THAT RIGHT?
AND THE PROBLEM IS NOW IT'S
NOT A MATTER OF OKAY, I
THINK THE AGE TO BUY GUNS
SHOULD BE RAISED TO 21 AND
NO, I THINK IT SHOULDN'T AND
HERE'S WHY.
IT'S ALWAYS YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU ARE A BAD PERSON.
YOU WANT CHILDREN TO DIE AS
A RESULT.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE SAW IT ON
THE CONSERVATIVE SIDE AS
WELL ON THE LIBERAL SIDE AS
FAR AS PEOPLE SAYING THAT
THESE CHILDREN ARE ACTORS.
PLEASE, I MEAN, I HAD A
FRIEND THAT HAD A DAUGHTER
IN THAT SCHOOL HIDING IN THE
CLOSET AND THE EMOTION IS
REAL.
I WOULD NEVER DOUBT THESE
KIDS IN TERMS OF THEIR
SENTIMENT AROUND.
THIS THEY ARE NOT BEING
COACHED.
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT LIBERALS WE BELIEVE IN